les italiens sont en train de mesurer
jour pour jour la gravité de la
situation et c'est effrayant ce qui se
passe les services de pompes funèbres
ont été complètement dépassés par la
quantité de morts des militaires qui
doivent s'occuper hélas d'aller d'aller
récupérer les cercueils de deux de ces
personnes hommes et femmes qui décèdent
comme à la guerre un après l'autre et on
s'est même temps on peut même pas les
saluer avec des obsèques dignes de ce
nom tellement l'urgence et et pressante
et voilà le message important je pense
pour un public ou six francophones c'est
de savoir que que la france aujourd'hui
à une chance énorme c'est à dire que ce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui en italie
risquent de se produire dans une dizaine
de jours en france donc
agissez tout de suite agir ça veut dire
se barricader à la maison respecter les
mesures de confinement faire vraiment
attention parce que même si l'ennemi est
invisible et je comprends qu'il est
difficile de le comprendre il est parmi
nous